the true history of ancient human
civilization is far older and was once
far more advanced than we were ever
taught in school and in this video I'm
going to tie together three examples
that prove that one the true age of
ancient human civilization is far older
by more than double than that of what
the textbooks have taught us - that
there was a massive global Cataclysm
that happened on earth when human
civilization was around and it was
essentially a total reset button for
human civilization that mankind was
obliterated back into the Stone Age and
had to start all over from scratch and
the third example proves that not only
were we alive at the time of the
Cataclysm but that we somehow had the
intellectual knowledge and capabilities
to build a massive network of more than
200 underground cities that are
completely unexplainable by scientists
archaeologists and historians some of
which are hundreds of feet underground
more than 11 levels deep have advanced
air ventilation systems in architecture
- have completely dumbfounded modern
engineers now I do have a video on the
Cataclysm but let me give you just a few
key pieces of evidence that prove this
that include the most recent and
technologically advanced scientific data
ever taken for example ice core samples
taken from both Antarctica
as well as Greenland proved that there
was two massive events the first that
happened approximately 12,000 980 years
ago and the second 1,400 years later or
11,000 600 years ago this showed that
there was a sudden rapid and massive 400
foot rise in global sea levels which may
have even have been 30 feet in the first
24-hour period of whatever this event
was it also shows a 15 degree fahrenheit
temperature swing which is incredible
because when you consider that global
warming and climate change debates right
now are focused on what will happen if
there's a three degree fahrenheit
temperature increase well this is five
times that also at that same time there
was a massive extinction level event
that killed off more than 75% of all
mammals in North America including 120
species of megafauna which are animals
larger than 100 pounds most of which
you've probably never seen or heard of
before but they were absolutely
incredible
another key piece of evidence that
happened at the same period of time is a
mysterious black matte layer similar to
the KT boundary that killed off the
dinosaurs as evidence of an asteroid
impact this covers over 50 million
square kilometers of the Earth's surface
nearly 25 percent of all the landmass
and evidence of it is found over three
continents in dozens of countries around
the world this black matte layer
includes iridium nano diamonds
extraterrestrial helium which is all
evidence of a cosmic impact that a comet
or an asteroid hit planet Earth but it's
completely mysterious because nobody has
found the crater that would be the
result of it however this would explain
the rapid end to the last ice age that
all happened at the same period of time
that essentially a comet or an asteroid
hit the North American ice shelf which
at the time was more than 1 mile thick
of ice and in some places more than 2
miles thick and if an asteroid was to
hit that ice shelf it would have caused
a massive fine of a tremendous amount of
ice as well as vaporizing a significant
amount of water into the atmosphere only
to be rained down over the entire planet
for days and weeks to come which
completely corresponds with the data
taken from Antarctica and Greenland on
opposite sides of the planet that show
that there was a massive 400-foot rise
in sea level and nobody can figure out
how this happened nobody has an
explanation as to why the last ice age
ended so rapidly and so suddenly now
this need to be in to my second point
which is that the true age of human
civilization is at least double than
what we were taught in the textbooks as
evidenced by the sight of Gobekli Tepe
located in Turkey this site is dated at
at least eleven thousand six hundred
years old and it is completely
mysterious nobody knows who built it why
or how but it is more than 7,000 years
older than Stonehenge which is largely
mysterious in and of itself and it is
also 50 times larger and only 5% of it
has been excavated
but ground-penetrating radar has shown
that so much of the site still remains
underground it contains more than 200
pillars some of which range from 20 to
50 tons in the site itself clearly has a
celestial orientation and what makes it
even more interesting is that as the
worlds
first north south facing structure but
it's lined perfectly north which is
completely unexplainable because there
was no way to do that even in modern
times without having advanced
astronomical knowledge also found at
this site is evidence of advanced
agriculture which wasn't supposed to
exist until nearly 6,000 years later by
the Sumerians in Mesopotamia also known
as the cradle of civilization this site
in itself completely debunked what we
were taught in our textbooks and that
the true narrative of ancient human
civilization is far older and far more
complicated than we ever realized
now Gobekli Cafe which is located in
Turkey as I mentioned leads me into my
third example which is that there is a
network of more than 200 underground
cities also located in Turkey in the
Cappadocia region the first thing that
must be mentioned about these cities is
that every scientist archaeologist and
historian all agrees that they are
completely mysterious they have no idea
when they were built who built them why
and especially how and like I said
earlier modern engineers are completely
baffled that they had the intellectual
knowledge to strategically build them in
the ways that they did that essentially
they carved around volcanic stone and
even new strategically where to place
specific pillars in order to ensure the
stability of the complex and they have
found zero evidence of any cave-ins
whatsoever which is pretty incredible
let me give you the example of Darren qu
which is the most notable of these
underground cities now this site has not
been fully excavated they don't know
exactly how deep it is or how many
levels
however National Geographic states it
has 11 and then it also has an advanced
air ventilation system that consists of
more than 50 main shafts that plummet
more than 200 feet into the earth or
more than 55 meters it also has more
than 15,000 sub shafts that stem out
from the 50 main shafts that they know
of the entire site of itself is huge it
spans across more than four square miles
or 10.4 kilometers and like I said it
has not been fully excavated it also
connects to a nearby city through a
eight kilometer or five mile long tunnel
carved out of volcanic rock more than
three stories underground it has
hundreds if not thousands of rooms
was capable of holding more than 20,000
people and livestock comfortably which
is completely mind-boggling considering
that out of these 200 known underground
cities more than 40 of them have at
least three levels or more some of which
have at least 10 levels that they know
of and they even have communication
piping holes connecting from various
levels to another so that way people can
communicate in them and they also have a
system of locking doors essentially
1,100 pound
rolling doors that could be operated by
one person that would prevent anyone
from the outside being able to get in
which many historians in archeologists
have stated that maybe the reason why
these underground cities were built or
to avoid Raiders and invaders to their
to their area which is pretty illogical
considering that there's more than 200
of these cities in fact there's a city
located 2,200 kilometers away nearly
1,400 miles in Iran known as the new
shabad underground city and if you look
at photos of it which I'll throw a
couple of here for you it looks like it
was built by the same people this could
also explain the mysterious city of
Petra which is more well known for
having been in the movie Indiana Jones
and the Last Crusade but it is
completely unexplainable they don't know
who built it and even just a year ago
they found a whole other entrance to it
and it may have held as many as 20,000
people which reminds me some of these
underground cities located in Turkey
were capable of holding more than 60,000
people for months on end according to
estimates again to think that these were
made just to stay away from invaders is
incredibly illogical isn't it far more
likely that we somehow had the
intellectual knowledge and the physical
capabilities to build these sites
knowing that there was a cataclysm
coming because again we have no idea who
built them there when and now that we
know that the history of human
civilization is far older and was once
far more advanced than what our
textbooks have actually told us it's
time that we start asking new questions
and start piecing together key pieces of
evidence so that we come up with far
more logical explanations to the true
history of human civilization so to
close this up we know that because of
gobekli tepe the history of human
civilization is at least double the age
than that of what we were taught in the
textbooks we know that they also had
advanced knowledge and that we'll take
in for a case
agriculture as well as the perfect
north/south facing so that we were
essentially ahead of ourselves and what
we thought we were capable of by at
least 6000 years and because of this we
know that we were alive at the precise
time of a massive Cataclysm
when there just so happens to be a
network of more than 200 underground
tunnels which to me seems like some type
of arc system for survival and when you
tie these three things together the most
logical explanation is that yes humans
were alive we were more advanced and we
were essentially wiped out anyways guys
I'll leave it at that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe I have many other videos
and a whole wide variety of topics take
care everybody